this morning we are learning more about
the cast in the first celebrity edition
of the CBS reality series Big Brother
the celebrity house guests include
television personality and former White
House aide Amorosa Manigault rock star
mark McGrath remember him from Sugar Ray
and The Cosby Show actress keshia knight
pulliam remember she was Rudy they will
live together in the Big Brother house
where they will be recorded 24/7 and
they'll compete to win special
privileges like head of household each
week at least two will get voted out of
the house the last remaining houseguests
will win a grand prize Julie Chen has
hosted all 19 seasons of Big Brother so
she said why stop now she will return to
host a special celebrity edition Julie
welcome back to the table
thank you know where we got to start
because last when we saw our heroine in
this story she was on Good Morning
America and Robin Roberts said bye
Felicia
now we're at CBS saying hey Felicia
you're saying from the White House to
the Big Brother house yes was it hard
was it hard to convince her to join
how'd this come about
well I will tell you for weeks the
producers were you know every few weeks
I would get a text or an email
conversation who do you have well we
think we might get Omarosa and I was
like good luck because you know we heard
we might get a lot of other big names
and and then you never know yeah because
it is a contract negotiation and but I
had a good feeling actually because I
thought well she's free she's free yeah
she's available no he's not free and we
know she likes a platform yeah a camera
she likes to be heard and now she can be
heard 24 says she has a consulting
reputation though Julie about sometimes
not being able to play nicely with
others are you worried about the well
this is the big brother or depending on
that mate we're depending on it right
that is the key ticket to take it all
the way a big brother
you want to win the grand prize yeah
which is a quarter of a million dollars
I believe not chump change I always
remind everybody if they haven't watch
the show to about the voting process
though well it is a little bit of
popularity yes you're right I mean it's
like a struggle between competing
against everyone for power
and then you have to get votes to stay
if you get nominated and every time
there's a new head of household he or
she is gonna nominate two people like I
could say Nora and John mm the two of
you up for eviction and the rest of the
house guys vote yeah so then you have to
start you know right 57th Street and
order your taxi
there's no Electoral College so was
someone say has come from a reality show
and is now engaged in now that would you
how much does politics going to be
something she brings in or is that
something she has to leave at the door
well you have to see who the other
houseguests are and how much they want
to talk about people talk about what
you're most excited about in terms of
the house guests who are coming other
than Omarosa yeah well what we've talked
about Rudy we talked about Sugar Ray
yes Russ the intern Ross the intern
we've got Shannon Elizabeth everyone's
crushed for American Pie she has a
serious hardcore poker player she
doesn't South Africa now we've got a
Chuck Liddell former MMA fighter talk
about competitor we've got Metta World
Peace used to be Ron Artest
used to be run our tests you know he has
a player the lakers name generator' what
would your big brother name be I never
knew on roses last name until like just
recently yeah so yes some people just
need only one name I'm also excited
about we have Brandi Glanville from
Beverly Hill you know and she's always
interesting to watch and I am curious
whether she and I morose are are either
gonna be best friends or bitter enemies
well I've seen you know I saw I've seen
parts of the show where they say look
this isn't personal I actually like you
but I'm voting against you so what makes
a good big brother dynamic for you for
interviewers it's seeing the human
struggle with okay we just became best
friends I just met you in the house but
now it's either I stab you in the back
for
half a million dollars the regular
version the non slurries have which will
be life-changing money for my you know
spouse and children or it and then the
dance that they have to face when they
walk out and they get either food or
cheered coming out of the house a lot of
people in that house think well you know
I'm such a lovable person and they come
out and it ones like it forces you to
look at yourself like this in the mirror
or you think you know you're a horrible
person but then everyone what I learned
is everybody is multifaceted yes you're
not all good you're not all bad and it's
our job to show all sides and the
cameras are everywhere so you get to see
all sides at all time 24/7 on the CBS
app each other yeah I can't sleep I'm
like what's happening in a house right
now Julie you're setting up an
interesting dynamic now see tonight
Julie Chen thank you have three more
slots if you guys are interested no
thanks right well we get back from the
mountain cliffs I have a pedicure in
Peru I'm very busy celebrity edition
premieres this Wednesday February 7th at
8/7 central right here on CBS